majuli is the largest river island in
the world and for five months during the
monsoon it's almost entirely underwater
[Music]
fresh water fish are plentiful and so
there's no better place to find a
delicious traditional fish curry
[Music]
i'm here to meet one of assam's most
celebrated chefs ato laka
he runs two restaurants and he's agreed
to show me one of his classic fish
curries
[Music]
how are you i'm fine good to see you
good to see you we start for fishing
pissing fishing oh fishing yes
you like fishing i love fishing yeah
because the people of us we like facing
let's hope atol's cooking is better than
his english
are you ready yeah i already did it you
move wait for me
yes come come come come but yeah but the
pranks don't work on mine this is my
place that's why i was 150 000 islanders
live here and they survive almost
entirely on a diet of fish and all that
comes from these fresh water ponds
99
the village live on fish yes yes
wow
jesus christ that boat's not going to
put up with a fat bastard like me i'll
tell you
about it
yeah i'm trying yeah i'm fine
that's good
well that was a [ __ ] start wasn't it see
i knew wouldn't take 50s
[Laughter]
sorry guys we apologized for me you were
so happy you're a lot lighter than i am
look how skinny these guys are
they're not even 60 kilos oh jeez
they're so light
these flimsy boats can't take a culinary
heavyweight like me so onto plan b
well we've got some more fish from the
market we've bought some fish and now
ato's going to cook denga
a traditional assamese fish curry that
has a truly unique flavor
and what's that called is it you did an
elephant apple uh-huh and what do they
taste like apples it's like choba chowa
yeah so they're acidic yeah it's this
tropical fruit that gives dengue its
signature sour flavour which will add
bite to the earthy taste of our
freshwater fish
so where's the recipe from everywhere
are some people use this type of fish
here they're scary okay
green chili very good
but no spices no no no only chili leaves
uh-huh yeah why is that our chili is so
special yeah so i noticed it the
varieties of chili right
chili you know that it's a hottest silly
wall yes so i ate a little child
yeah garlic
what have you got in there what have you
put in
here
excellent
good
[Music]
and is that you done then yeah
but my goodness your curry is finished
cherry in a hurry
you like my traditional elisa miss food
the cow is delicious
and you've managed to make it with no
spices yeah so i totally understand
where you're coming from it's been
really good thank you thank you thank
you now just before i go
i want you to say one thing for me
fishing fishing snake snack
no it's not good
snake snake
atoll suggested that i spend some time
with these misses she's going to show me
exactly how she cooks if there's one way
of going back to calcutta with some
really
exciting stunning dishes it's going to
be from this competition
yes
hello rashford how are you i'm fine i'm
fine nice to see you good to see you
finally okay this is a first for me
entering a domestic
competition actually today i'm going to
show you how to cook chicken with sesame
seed chicken with sesame seed yes and
who taught you this dish yeah i i just
learned it from my mother for my granny
i always do my cooking at home because
atul he doesn't like to cook at home
he's better in his restaurant he's like
me oh [ __ ] you know why why we haven't
got the staff at home oh
get that nice nice this is the mustard
oil oh yeah that is
we never use refine oil what we prefer
is the mustard oil right and that's the
flavor yeah we prefer less oil i feel
like i'm back at school with my home
economic teacher
do i look like a teacher yeah yeah
young and sexy oh
cool cool
wow
so onions garlic chilies do you put them
in hole yeah yeah oh the chicken in it's
quite dry but
we don't use too much of oil that's why
very slim and beautiful
he's a lucky man thank you i do lots of
yoga you know yoga yoga oh too boring
for me yoga
rashmi's healthy family recipe then uses
fresh turmeric and coriander the color
has to remain green so it's a green
curry jesus this is a housewife
competition you're so serious and so
strict
it will remain green yes i promise yeah
that smells
delicious
color looks amazing yes
i don't recognize the final ingredient
it's black sesame seed paste and it's
only used in northeast indian curries
okay good it's very tempting isn't it it
is very tempting it is delicious it
looks fantastic yeah
are you hungry uh i am a little bit i
don't like to eat before i go into
competitions
you are very nervous
nervous energy yes yes yes the real
point you know since you are nervous you
don't want to eat well i have a little
taste
yeah it's very good everything is
perfect
yeah everything i'm not going to say
down i'm going to say chef thank you
thank you thank you you're most welcome
that is delicious fingers crossed
i think atoll's misses might actually be
a better cook than he is
so this is a token of love for me
and just you're going to wheel it it's a
good luck okay
three tablespoons of garlic ginger
trying to place sesame seed paste at the
end at the end
hello
jesus
the best dish in assam is a much sought
after title
[Music]
yes i'm here to yeah i'm here to cook
i'll love this thank you indeed
amazing
my 40 fellow competitors have been
perfecting the recipes for months but i
want to give them a run for their money
ready steady we start like oh [ __ ]
i'm feeling pretty confident i just need
to remember what goes in first
[Music]
little smell darling little smell
yeah not too much garlic
no
okay good
right lid on keep an eye on that for me
please yeah
and just turn down the gas a little bit
and have a little wander
while that reduces i'm sneaking off to
spy on the competition
[Music]
and this one is
pigeon
that smells nice though what's this one
here
opium
[ __ ]
opium
poppy seeds
poppy seeds
and this is
chicken chicken oh i'm doing chicken as
well what else have you got in there
onions garlic onions
and
ginger so everyone's doing a little bit
of decoration aren't they
is that for your decoration
wow okay right i'll go get my ass in
together and do some decorations this
lot might look like india's answer to
the wi but they're actually pretty good
cooks they're now garnishing their
dishes it's gone up a notch bloody how
they started out as a sort of domestic
sort of
you know local competition they know
what they're doing crafty buggers well
two can play that game
have done one of these things as a
college
a little van dyke
of tomato
15 minutes left yes thank you thank you
ainsley coyander in
please come out the same killer's
rushing
[Music]
i've got to stay green okay sesame seed
paste in four minutes you have to come
to the presentation table
the countdown begins yep
i've never been so much in this [ __ ] in
all my life you know
stop
please [ __ ]
all the participants please go and take
your seats the judges will
taste your food and give their
marks first runners up
first of all what's up mr gordon
runner up or did i wait
can you give him another play oh [ __ ]
he's only number two he's not one okay
well got to be grateful excellent thank
you
thank you
thank you thank you very much
thank you thank you very much
says
sees none other than tech number 14
congratulations what was the dish
chicken again
what did she do to the chicken that i
didn't do papaya
papaya with chicken yeah okay
excellent
a panasonic pressure cooker
yes
i love you all
thank you
i don't like coming second best okay
next year i'm coming back oh yes
number one
thank you
papaya and chicken that sounds
interesting now doesn't it yeah and i
mean okay i didn't win fine but what i
did come here for was to pick up some
knowledge to see how i can put that in
to the streets of calcutta thank you
ladies
thank you russian dean good bye how are
you
good to see you
excellent and this is annie's
sagu
zagat are you sure they're not bonking
off school no no no definitely he's not
i didn't adopt him okay right
first thing i need um
the fire lighting
i'm going to draw on the unique flavors
of the northeast to create three
delicious curries
my first is chicken and green papaya
inspired by the winning recipe at the
cooking competition
it will have that classic asami sour
tang that the locals won't be used to
green papaya helps it not just soften
the chicken but marinate it also gives
that really nice tart
flavor i'm going to make a fish curry
using the dried bamboo shoot from
nagaland
it's something of an acquired taste and
i don't know how it'll go down here
it's a combination of a sort of bay leaf
stroke lemongrass with a little hint of
licorice
first time for you i'm so pleased
my final dish is a north eastern take on
vegetable curry instead of using dried
spices i'm using fresh ones making a
more subtle flavor
finish with a puree of sesame seed
almost thickened vegetable curry with a
sesame seed paste
and then
after that
the fresh coriander paste
just one last thing to do before i open
my stall
i am sweating like a pig i look like a
pig i stink like a pig right i'm gonna
get changed
right cooler much better
so it's not exactly chef whites is it
but i suppose it's uh it's equivalent my
local chef wise to tell you why it's a
lot cooler huh nothing wrong with going
commander in the midday sun
time to see if my take on the northeast
curries can win over calcutta's foodies
[Music]
you must stress
that it's from the north east yeah you
must tell them that that's nice tell me
how i say
okay
let's go fish curry certainly sir
actually this is a new thing to us in
calcutta i don't know
other people will like it or not
but in my opinion
it's really a super bonus
let's go let's go let's go
the food is very good
and uh
i have the face with bamboo shoots
it's very tasty
bamboo
with green papaya thank you let's go
chicken papaya has gone down a storm
extraordinary it was really good i've
never tasted a bamboo
and the vegetables and these are really
good last chicken
lovely that is unbelievable
that's barely 50 minutes
over 100 portions of chicken's gone
which is fantastic news
with the last of the chicken papaya gone
my fish and vegetable curries quickly
sell out too
so
thank you that is now officially gordon
ramsay's calcutta cafe closed finished
it's been a great day i've enjoyed
myself and judging by the reaction my
career has been a success
500
600 700 800 900 1000 2000.
that my son is a good morning's work
okay yes thanks
every people say the food is excellent
today definitely everybody said that
but there's one person's opinion that
really matters food writer non don's
arrived to give me his verdict
hi gordon
how are you doing brother how are you
i'm good how was your week uh my week
has been amazing so what did you cook up
today so today we did a um a take on a
chicken with green papaya we did an
amazing fish carry i saved you a little
portion because i was getting slightly
worried
[Music]
no wonder you sold out
thank you believe me
you happy with that
not only that you have actually
succeeded in doing something many people
would have said is impossible well done
that's very kind of
very well done very well done
i look ridiculous i must have lost half
my body weight in sweat but i've proved
that curries of the northeast of india
are worth shouting about
i thought
my first week in india was a
eye-opener
this one was a shock i think because
it's hard to believe that exists it's
almost like you weren't in india
the culture is equally as exciting as
the food
just
an amazing eye opener
the simplicity the concentration of
great ingredients and not pissing around
with it
india's helped me to become
you know not just you know a proper chef
i've never i was never out that bracket
but it it's helped me to confirm what i
love doing more than anything
can we top that
i doubt it but i can't [ __ ] wait to
try
you